Apple is the most valuable publicly traded
company in the world.
And Elon Musk hasn’t shied away from trying to take another bite out of the company.
The drama surfaced when Wall Street Journal
reporter Tim Higgins came out with a book
about Tesla that included a wild claim.
That Elon Musk tried to replace Tim Cook as
Apple’s CEO.
According to the book, at the height of Tesla’s
problems with mass-producing its most affordable
vehicle, the Model 3, in 2016, Cook suggested
to Musk that Apple buy Tesla, at which point
Musk lobbied to take over Cook’s job.
Cook is said to have angrily hung up the phone
but not before unleashing an expletive.
(F*& you).
Both men have denied the conversation
took place.
This is what Cook told the New York Times’
Kara Swisher on her podcast Sway:
“You know, I’ve never spoken to Elon,
although I have great admiration and respect
for the company he’s built.”
Musk made the point of saying they’ve “...never
spoken or written to each other ever.”
However, he admitted that during Tesla’s
toughest days, he did request a meeting with
Cook to talk about the prospect of Apple acquiring
Tesla.
But there weren’t any conditions involved.
Musk went on to say that Cook “refused to
meet” with him.
And added at the time, Tesla was
worth only 6 per cent of its current valuation.
Who knows what an Apple acquisition might
have looked like. After all, Musk isn’t
exactly the company’s biggest fan.
During Tesla’s second-quarter earnings call,
he made a point of saying Apple uses more
cobalt than Tesla does.
Some cobalt mined in conflict areas like the
Congo has been linked to child labor.
And the mining process has been blamed for
devastating the environment.
It is, however, the key ingredient in lithium-ion
batteries that power iPhones and electric cars.
Tesla has since announced it’s starting
to shift toward cobalt-free iron phosphate
(LFP) batteries instead.
For Apple’s part, it has said its long-term
goal is to not mine cobalt at all, but rather,
recycle old iPhones and recover cobalt for
re-use.
Musk has snipped at Apple many times.
For example, in response to Apple kicking
Fortnite off the App Store for violating Apple’s policies.
The game’s developer, Epic Games, had tried
to get around Apple’s 30% cut of App Store
revenue by implementing its own in-app payment
system.
Epic is now suing Apple for its meaty cut
of revenue.
Musk showed his support for Epic by tweeting:
“Apple app store fees are a de facto global
tax on the internet.
Epic is right.”
He’s spoken out about what he feels is Apple’s
anti-competitive behavior.
“Our goal is to support the advent of sustainable
energy.
It is not to create a walled garden and use
that to bludgeon our competitors, which is
sometimes used by some companies.
(Cough) Apple (cough).”
Musk appeared to fake a cough and mutter “Apple.”
Turns out, the two companies could soon be
directly competing with one another.
Apple has reportedly been quietly developing
an autonomous electric vehicle since 2014
that is meant to give Tesla a run for its money.
Though Musk appeared to write it off early
on, telling the German newspaper Handelsblatt
in 2015: “It’s good that Apple is moving
and investing in this direction.
But cars are very complex compared to phones
or smartwatches.”
But Cook doesn’t see a self-driving car
as anything but technology.
Though he’s played coy about what exactly Apple
has in the works.
Would it be in the form of a car or the technology
within a car?
I’m not going to answer that question.
Apple is well known for keeping things under
tight wraps.
It has reportedly held talks with several
car companies about teaming up to build an
electric car though it’s apparently still
searching for a partner.
So an electric Apple car - if it ever appears
- could still be years away.
Musk doesn’t think Apple has the right people
to get it done, saying it has hired people
Tesla has fired, likening Apple to a graveyard
filled with those who couldn’t cut it at Tesla.
But then he appeared to dial back the criticism,
clarifying: “I don’t hate Apple.
I'm glad they're doing an EV.”
Whether Apple ends up coming out with a car
or not, it’s already well known as one of
the most transformative companies in history.
Apple has created an ecosystem where its devices
are designed to work seamlessly with one another
which entices fans to buy them all.
In this regard, it appears as if Musk is trying
to take a page out of Apple’s book.
Tesla is now looking to expand its own ecosystem
by going beyond cars.
It already offers solar roofs for homes that
generate energy that can be stored in a Tesla
powerwall that can power your house when the
grid goes down.
The powerwall can also charge your Tesla.
And your car can be covered by Tesla’s own
insurance, just like Apple Care covers Apple products.
The Tesla ecosystem seems to be ever-expanding.
Musk has said he’s keen to develop a Tesla
HVAC system - a heating, ventilation, and
air conditioning system, bringing the tech
developed from its cars into homes.
The entrepreneur believes the key to a successful
company lies in its ability to rapidly innovate
and create heart-stopping products.
He thinks that Apple used to wow the world,
but not anymore, as he once told Kara Swisher.
“Apple used to really bring out products
that would blow peoples’ minds, you know?
And they still, make great products, but there's
less of that.
I don't think people are necessarily running
to the store for the iPhone 11.”
Still, it hasn’t stopped Musk from continuing
to use his very own Apple iPhone.
Anyone who's bought shares in either Apple
or Tesla and has held them for long enough
is reaping the rewards.
But there’s always volatility with the stock
market.
What if you could shelter yourself from the
crazy bull market by investing in ultra-expensive
famous works of art?
Art doesn’t generally react to market volatility
in the same way as other assets.
Imagine if you could own a Warhol or a Banksy.
Normally reserved for the uber-wealthy.
Well, my sponsor, Masterworks, lets you buy
shares in ultra-high-end art, just like investing
in Tesla.
Masterworks acquires multi-million-dollar
artworks from the best artists.
And allows you and me to invest in shares
in these expensive paintings that have been
securitized by the SEC.
When Masterworks sells the art, or if you
sell your shares to other members on their
secondary market, the rewards could be enormous.
From 1995 to 2020, Fine art appreciated at
14 per cent a year, outperforming the S&P 500.
The art market is currently valued at $6 trillion
and is expected to grow by over $1 trillion
in the next five years, according to Deloitte.
If you’d like to join over 250,000 people
who have already signed up for Masterworks,
you can head to the custom link in my description.
It only takes a few minutes, and you can instantly
diversify your portfolio with one of the most
stable assets around.
Thanks so much for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.